you know what we didn't talk about so
you're from harlem definitely
uh
what were your thoughts on the lox dip
set
versus
uh i know it's been a while now but i'm
just curious you know obviously
dipset being the biggest entity to ever
represent that harlem flag you know
uh what were your thoughts on what
happened there i think
i think with the dip set locks versus
first of all shout out to the dip set
shout out to the locks what they did
with the verses was monumental because
you never seen it like that that [ __ ]
looked like a concert
definitely you had never seen people
that close to the stage you've never
seen that many people on the stage right
i've never seen that people around she
looks like summer jam or something that
[ __ ] was a it was a real event and
in in harlem fashion you know they had
to show up fashion and be late you know
[ __ ] from yonkers was like get your
ass out here and they made it a show and
it was entertaining right i like that
and i like the fact that even through
watching it i was like damn kim's they
pulling styles pulling cam's shoe and
oh no it was crazy they took the bandana
and threw it on the floor and then elves
and they was all in their face go uptown
to harlem and i'm like i love it
but at the end to see them be like yo we
about to go on tour
that did it
that did it for me it's like oh this
they did this for the city they did this
for the culture